well a week ago I interviewed two former
angling stars who quit the England
women's team over a transgender teammate
they thought had an unfair advantage of
sports interational governing body has
now ruled that male born competitors
cannot take on women because their
physical power gives them an unfair
Advantage so some common sense again
prevailing in the world of women's sport
but the Fight Continues in many other
women's sports Canadian powerlifter
April Hutchinson has taken a stand
against trans women in herbort facing a
backlash for doing so well now a video's
emerged of rival Anne andrees a male to-
female trans athlete who holds the
women's record in Canada appearing to
mock women for being weak why is women's
bench so bad I mean not compared to me
we all know that I'm a freak so
that doesn't count I know we're not
talking about Mackenzie Lee she's got
little T-Rex arms and she's like 400 lbs
of chest muscle apparently I mean
standard bench in powerlifting
competition for women I literally don't
understand why it's so
bad well Team Canada powerlifter aelon
joins me now well welcome to P thank you
for coming to the studio um an andrees
who is a biological male who's
transgendered currently holds four of
the five provincial records the highest
deadlift of all ages in Canada um if an
Andre competed with males then she would
place around
6,000 there right there is the
inequality the unfairness that we're
seeing in many sports but particularly a
sport like yours yeah so you have
powerlifting which is a pure strength
sport um males have an advantage of 60
to 70% advantage over females you hear
Ann talking about the bench press why is
bench press so weak for females we're
not designed for bench press we don't
have the the right muscle mass for a
bench press so therefore we will be
weaker when you hit here her mocking
really the whole situation how does that
make you feel I mean it's it's the whole
thing is disgusting it's it's
disgraceful it's disheartening it's uh
even more disheartening that the
Federation allows this to happen I am
the one being punished for speaking
truth yet he can mock females and say
you know call me a bigot uh inight hate
and nothing's being done about that but
I'm the one being silenced by my
Federation what is going to happen to
you well most recently uh I I've been
threatened with suspension uh two weeks
ago I received a letter from my
Federation stating that you cannot call
an a biological male that goes against
the code of ethics you know because in
their policy we do ask that we use
pronouns they don't force you to but
they ask also um but but but she is a
biological male I mean I'm perfectly
prepared to call her an her name that
she prefer to be called that's fine but
she's a biological male a transgender
athlete who's now
destroying female competitors in women's
sport I mean to me again but
particularly in this uh powerlifting
it's so obvious that if someone would
come
6,000 competing against men but is
winning against women there's the
problem exactly now just recently the
strongman Corporation in Canada uh we
spoke out against they had a transgender
athlete they actually changed their
policy to create a separate category so
simple and that's all we've been asking
is for a separate category to me it's
very simple what what should happen is
you either compete against your
biological sex so if you're a transwoman
you would compete against biological
males as most of them have done before
in sport massively less successfully it
should be noted or you have a completely
new category easy peasy yeah you think
it'd be that easy but yes and there
because there are far more people now
identifying as men or women different to
their biological sex these categories
would be quite well
I would imagine well sto with people
right there be lots of people wanted to
do it no exactly yeah well my Federation
actually I think they've gone Rogue
they've done their own thing they've
created an inclusion policy so you could
identify as a female Toral Pierce take
all the records crush it in the women's
category and then go back to being a man
the next day that I mean that's
something Martina vova said very early
on and she was accused of being a big
one of the biggest
lgbtq Advocates probably ever in sport
she was accused of being bigoted I this
is the sort of go this is the sort of I
don't know what you call it it's the
instant reaction every time anyone in
your position or Martina or whatever
they raise a concern about this obvious
unfairness if I would call it cheating I
mean just is cheating to me it has the
same effect as doping right in the sense
it gives somebody an unfair Advantage we
all know this but people like you brave
enough to put your head of the parit you
get shot down and called bigoted
transphobic and so on well exactly I
mean I've been called that word I don't
know how many times now I am it's not
transphobic to ask for fairness in
women's sports it's a word they use to
silence you well I'm not going to be Sil
you have any problem with transgender
people no not at all not at all I I have
a problem with uh transgender athletes
going into women's sports or AKA
biological men taking women's Podium
spots sponsors uh medals and you never
see it the other way around with trans
men exactly never it doesn't happen
because trans Men actually have an
inferior disadvantage when they against
biological men obviously because they're
biological femal so there's a reason I
always say there's a reason the Olympics
you split the genders up if you didn't
if you made it gender neutral the next
Olympics women would win about two gold
medals if they were lucky in the entire
tournament well there's a reason why
there's categories I'm in the master so
I compete between 40 and 50 years old
yeah there's people from 50 to 60
there's Juniors like I could identify as
a junior tomorrow and go crush the
Juniors right exactly and if you had to
compete in your category a 40 to 50
Masters against only biological males
who are identified now as women but have
competed in powerlifting in that
category how would you get on oh well I
think it answers for itself not well so
I mean you wouldn't win anything right
no nothing so your chances of being able
to be successful in your sport are
massively eroded simply because people
with an unfair physical Advantage have
come along and decided they want to be
you exactly and and this particular
person an I mean he's taken records that
basically people that have been training
for 10 years haven't even touched a
number like a deadlift of 573 pounds is
unheard of especially by a 40-year old
are you going to sue the Federation well
I I do have an attorney um that's in the
works right now I do have to respond to
their letter of disciplinary but it is
in the works yes and I'm actually um
raising money right now for legal fees
to pay the lawyers I think it is
ridiculous that people like you are put
through this hell for spelling out the
bleeding obvious I do think it's
ridiculous and we keep hammering this on
this program because I think most
right-minded people know how ridiculous
it is and how unfair it is but thank you
for coming in I wish you good luck and
we will keep hammering this drum until
Common Sense prevails in every sport yes
for sure and I just want to uh give you
this as a gift because it is women's
History Month in Canada ah so I made the
shirt for you keep female sports female
can let's make this Global as well you
know what I will happily endorse that
t-shirt because they should be and
women's uh rights to fairness and
equality should Trump stupid allegations
of being transphobic I have no problem
with any trans people I wish them all
the very best I want them to have
fairness and equality in their lives
absolutely but not when it erose women's
rights to fairness and equality that is
just unfair and unequal thanks for
coming
in